i sit over here all right that music ran
out really quickly
usually the music carries the guest over
to the chair what are you guys on strike
or something
unless they're bringing gifts i'm
supposed to put another quarter in there
how are you pretty good i um i brought
you some pie ah that's great
terrific some dingleberries yeah there
you go
we're building on a theme it's gonna be
let's hope ben folds has some yeah that
would be great
well happy thanksgiving and you can i
ask you if you put something in your
hair or have you been electrocuted
what's happening
i mean i like it i'm a big fan of
product in hair but that that's so
there's a lot of product in there yeah
it's called fudge
is it is that what it's like do whatever
you want oh
oh wow oh man look it's like teflon
it's weird yeah i do well in this play i
wear i
uh it's not actual fudge the product is
called
fudge because it looks like your
interview is being shot upside down
yeah it's just stuff that i i have to
wear in the play because i have to
mold my hair in a few different shapes
right
um and uh and i've kind of gotten
addicted to it and i actually
do you leave it in for a long period of
time or do you wash it out every time i
wash it out and then i put it back in
i've got i went away actually uh i was
in
mystic connecticut this weekend and uh i
was late for the show so my girlfriend
had to pack
my luggage and when we got there uh she
had forgotten and i just remember i was
from the other room calling honey did
you pack my fudge
and i did totally didn't totally didn't
realize it was going with that
that's my favorite that's that's my
favorite episode of three's company yeah
yeah
and don knotts is listening
uh happy thanksgiving though in all
sincerity
it is nice to have you where are you
gonna celebrate do you have some place
you can go are you gonna
going out i'm going to this bar called
molly's molly shabeen
is this a sad thing that you're going to
a bar is it a happy thing it sounds kind
of sad now that i think about it
yeah i've gone there a couple times for
thanksgiving it's this great bar
and uh they do a really nice
thanksgiving spread
and it's down it's here in the city yeah
it's uh it's on uh
it's on 22nd street and third avenue and
uh
i the last thanksgiving i spent there
was a few years ago
with some some friends we all came in
into the city met at molly's and some
friend was actually coming
they had flown in from california and he
met this couple on the plane this
australian couple
and uh so he was joining us for
they were joining us for our
thanksgiving dinner and he was a really
charismatic interesting guy
that was here kind of uh with business
opportunities
and he was uh like an entrepreneur he's
like yeah yeah kind of
uh but all enter environmentally sound
business opportunities like what's an
example of the things he was pitching
one of the things he pitched us was um
an engine that runs on air
he he was telling us that there was this
engine that was like new engine that ran
on air
and then there was another one that was
a tree that grew an inch a day an engine
that runs on air is a balloon deflating
but we'll just go back to basics the
answers are right there and um
what was the second one a tree that grew
an inch a day
he would and he suckered us in he was a
con man right
and we were we all had our checkbooks
out we were really ready to kind of
give him like gifts in some of these
ideas and then he finally said
you know it's the greatest uh speech and
actors ever giving on the environment
the greatest actor ever to give a speech
on the environment it's the worst
australian accent
i've ever heard and and we said what and
he said
steven segal on deadly ground
and then we put our checkbooks we lost
us
that's where he always loses people yeah
that's he went one step too far
you know whenever i try an australian
accent i just stick to g'day
and shrimp on the bob it's probably the
best thing to do and if i ever was an
actor and i had to play an australian
guy i would have to
the speech rewritten so it was just
alternating those words
now here comes mr phelps g'day shrimp on
bobby
bobby shrimp your day good day barbie
shrimp
and they'd have to chiron what the hell
i was talking about or you could also
just say
australian for beer
that would get you yeah that's not a
noise this is a knife
just memorize crocodile dundee movies
how's the um
how's the play going it's going really
well yeah yeah
yeah you like doing you like doing live
theater is it because i
always think that would be kind of scary
here if something goes wrong
i can edit it yeah that's not actually
true we don't have the money for that
but
some days it can be uh yeah a little
a little uh embarrassing sometimes when
things happen that aren't supposed to
and you can edit it out last month
uh rachel vice gretchen mall and
frederick weller
where the four of us are doing the show
but uh rachel weiss and i had this scene
in uh in bed and we're laying in bed and
the sheets are
covering us and we're both in boxer
shorts so it doesn't really matter
anyway
but we're kind of playing around it's a
sweet scene and um
the sheets actually had fallen down and
i had my leg up and i was talking to
rachel over here and
and didn't um quite realize until i
heard
some rumbling from the audience that my
leg was up and my boxers were hanging
down
and it's you know everyone has the fly
down on stage story
but um i was actually just kind of
hanging brain i was
really just all out there
and uh
and maybe my least favorite phrase ever
you know your most favorite it's hard to
know it's so least favorite it's coming
back around to most favorites i've been
on the show what now four minutes i
think we've
we've had pack and fudge hanging brain
and dingleberry that's might be a new
new record for them sadly that isn't
even close to the record on this show
the dirtiest show on television yeah so
wait what do you do when you realize
you're i'm gonna just join in here when
you realize your hanging brain in that
situation
what do you do you you you get the
sheets back over you first of all
right and then you just try and play out
the rest of the scene knowing the entire
the other thing too it wasn't just brain
it was it was everything all right okay
i don't want to know
i don't want to know what your euphemism
for the rest of it is
brain stem
i just love the people watching who
don't know what you're talking about
there are only two of them uh well
the shape of things which hey a lot of
us are going to go see this now
i think the police are raiding it
tomorrow all right you into the paddy
wagon uh
it's playing at the promenade theater in
uh new york city paul thank you for
being here
thank you on this day paul run everyone
we'll take a break when we come back ben
folds stick around